the earth you may know it as that blue
thing Bruce Willis is always trying to
save or from its famous collaboration
with wind and fire or just simply as
that place where George Clooney lives
anyway the earth had some genuinely bad
news this week a White House report that
says global warming threatens every part
of the US this isn't something in the
distant future climate change is already
affecting us now now
smart move Obama that is a key shift in
how to talk about climate change cuz
we've all proven that we cannot be
trusted with the future tense
we've been repeatedly asked don't you
want to leave a better earth for your
grandchildren and we've all collectively
responded yeah fuck'em but incredibly
this latest damning scientific report
may still face an uphill climb with some
of us there's that Gallup poll that came
out last month which found one in four
Americans is skeptical of all the
effects of climate change and thinks
this issues been exaggerated who gives a
that doesn't matter
you don't need people's opinions on a
fact you might as well have a poll
asking which number is bigger 15 or 5 or
do owls exist or are their hats
the debate on climate change should not
be whether or not it exists it's what we
should do about it there is a mounting
of research on this topic global
temperatures are rising heat waves are
becoming more common sea surface
temperatures are also rising glaciers
are melting and of course no climate
report is complete without the
obligatory photo of a polar bear
balancing on a piece of ice the only
accurate way to report that one out of
four Americans are skeptical of global
warming is to say a poll finds that one
out of four Americans are wrong about
something because a survey of thousands
of scientific papers that took a
position on climate change found that
97% endorsed the position that humans
are causing global warming and I think I
know why people still think this issue
is open to debate because on TV it is
and it's always one person for one
person against and it's usually the same
person for Bill Nye and Marsha Blackburn
welcome both of you to Meet the Press
Bill Nye joins us now along with climate
change skeptic mark Marana joining me
now to go head-to-head Bill Nye signs
educated and see other punchy society in
the crossfire Bill Nye the Science Guy
Bill Nye the Science Guy who believes in
manmade global warming yeah that's right
more often than not it's Bill Nye the
Science Guy versus some dude and and
when you look at the screen it's 50/50
which is inherently misleading if there
has to be a debate about the reality of
climate change and there doesn't then
there is only one mathematically fair
way to do it last week tonight presents
a statistically representative climate
change debate good evening joining me
tonight a climate change denier and
naturally Bill Nye science guy yep
humans are causing climate change no
wait wait wait wait before we begin on
in the interest of mathematical balance
I'm going to bring out two people who
agree with you climate skeptic and Bill
Nye I'm also going to bring out 96 other
scientists it's a little unwieldy but
this is the only way we can actually
have a representative discussion all
right so yeah please please file in
again again this is this is going to
make the debate difficult we shouldn't
really be having it in the first place
but so representational e climate
skeptic please make a case against
climate change
I just don't think all the sciences in
yet it's settled okay and what is the
overwhelming view of the entire
scientific community
I thought he charging Devils
all debate should not have happened I
apologize to everyone at home my thanks
to Bill Roy and the overwhelming
scientific consensus